the Joe Rogan experience you know at the
end of the day when you think about my
shows it's a very full-on experience
like when I when I put on a show I'm
trying to like I'm trying to come
compound all the senses you know I want
to be entertaining as hell I want it to
be fun engaging I want you to leave
knowing that you saw a steve aoki show
so that's why i try to do different
unique things like you know i cake
people i don't know if you know this
cake people at my shows take them you
hit them in the head it takes yeah I
would say the head but yeah but this is
all consensual by the way so I'll give
you a little story this so you know I
think as you are on the stage all the
time
you want to make your skits do you want
to make you everything that you do
unique to Joe Rogan you know like you
don't want to be like oh yeah he's a
copy of this person no one wants to be
that you know so I'm thinking like what
am I gonna do it's going to be unique
and different engaging
hey-ho you know like everyone's doing
that everyone sit down everyone jump so
you know I'm like you know your brains
always thinking so I got an idea after a
song that I really sell my label I have
my own label and we we released this
artist where the video was cakes
exploding in people's faces super slow
motion high-def really beautiful and
then I was like you know what I'm gonna
go to a bakery I'm gonna buy a cake
scribble like the song on the top of the
cake and let's just see what happens
it'll be funny little thing you know and
I brought the kisses 2011 mind you so
this is seven years or however long ago
that was you know a long time ago didn't
do the math anyway so it was a long time
ago and I walked around the front of
stage and won that one of the kids in
the front one of the guys front was like
why is he walking around the front like
am I supposed to like grab it and then
he just starts pointing at his face and
then all his friends around him are
pointing at him and the whole place was
just staring and waiting and watching
and wondering what the hell is gonna
happen
so I caked him we filmed it before this
is pre Instagram put up on YouTube it's
like I gotta do
- oh this is incredible and then six
months later people started coming out
with cake me signs
six years later okay here we go
so six years later like if I think I've
caked over 15,000 people now you know
you had it right in the mug - dude
perfect shot I'll tell you I mean you
know it's just practice makes perfect
you know you've shown 15,000 cakes I get
together you get a feel for a look at
her she's dancing yeah
wiping it out will we see more time this
is like that was ultra oh my goodness we
have a cake rider we have very specific
cakes that are you know at our show you
have it's like a special aoki cake what
isn't it the strange thing is there's
like not as much cake as you'd think
it's just like frosting it's just so it
just explodes everywhere so it's less
bread yes just so like less carbs more
sugar
well you diabetic just get out of the
front roll please crazy thing for people
to enjoy - yeah caked in the face yeah
it was having a good [ __ ] time yeah
that's okay that's the most important
thing at the end of the day is like it
shows cake made with a bull's eye okay
this is very normal for me to see you
know like some cases there's like 50 50
people with signs up no crazy look at
that cake face yeah I mean it's just of
it's a signature part of the show it's
fun it's exciting
dude I need to go to one of your shows
because everybody that I know that's
been says it's a wild experience it's
not just music it's just there's
something like you're doing something
transformative you know that people come
out of there they're just like whoo
they're buzzin yeah yeah I am that's the
goal you know and if I if I feel like
I'm doing that if I feel like I'm really
having this impact then I go that not
that's why I end up doing like so many
shows because I on average I'm doing
about 250 shows around the world every
year that is so crazy
and I do this I've done this
consistently for over 12 years so it's
it's
it's not like an artist that just drops
an album and then they tour like around
the world for a year or two like I'm on
I'm on a worldwide tour you know every
every single year is that sustainable
how's your body holding up yeah I work
out a lot yeah you're really in health
and wellness and all that stuff but that
seems insane basically with all the
travel it does I mean you have to you
have to like treat yourself at like an
athlete that's for sure the way I think
about my regimen is different